tristan thompson got another baby with
another woman
what a [ __ ] idiot he is one of the
all-time [ __ ] losers in the history
of the world it's unbelievable just a
[ __ ] loser through and through in
every way possible so this is his third
baby mama yes cheating on his girl every
time
and then he basically he sent a message
to the girl which he denies sending but
it's his contact info in the [ __ ]
screenshot yeah basically saying when
she got pregnant hey i'll give you 75
000 that's all you're gonna get from me
i'm gonna retire next year and he knows
the [ __ ] child support laws well
enough that he's like since i'm
unemployed you'll just get like whatever
percentage of unemployment and i'm not
gonna be the kids live i'm not gonna be
in your child's life so you should just
get the ability to cough up five hundred
thousand you're such a [ __ ]
millionaire like if you really don't
want that kid
call from a million you're still saving
money on a kid so think about the
[ __ ] 60 what was his contract 60
million the one that he got before he's
had others since
that's when they gave that to call her
daddy [ __ ] we all lost our minds for
him that's like a normal nba salary he
has got [ __ ] you money for generations
and i'm sure his other kids are well
taken care of they're trying to slow
ball is bigger and he tried to lowball
this [ __ ] you're [ __ ] scumbag dude
yeah just a loser through and through i
[ __ ] what a loser dude yeah
you already wiped chloe you know i
thought you couldn't get more pathetic
than that dog
that's too far i went too far with that
remember what all the girls were like i
like chloe i want to be like her that
[ __ ] done vanished huh i haven't heard a
[ __ ] you want to be like chloe in about
a decade yeah
god when was the last time i got was
faithful to her she used to be the ugly
fun one
and then she got so much super insecure
you always get cheated on one yeah yeah
[ __ ]
but deion sanders should bring tristan
to speak to his players
this what will happen to you yeah
[Laughter]
which one the hot ones no
he got the ugly one alex just said it
don't put this all on me
she's post-searching yeah the other
kardashian [ __ ] ugly
still who are you rather [ __ ] caitlyn or
chloe
oh chloe
oh chloe you just know you just said
chloe that's who he's with or that's who
is the mother of his kid
right like that's not loser [ __ ] it's a
kardashian yeah stop cheating on this
[ __ ]
impregnating other women why are you
copying please for tristan
hey hey jesus will talk to you at the
gates mark or whatever you [ __ ] said
earlier
uh
yeah
yeah whatever i do i try to call back to
you know that [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude this is a tricky one
what's tricky
it's it's tricky because uh
he [ __ ] up by not paying more and i'm
surprised he didn't come back with more
like
he could have offered her an amount and
she would have gotten that abortion yes
everybody got an amount yes
so
and if she's smart she knows he's a
[ __ ] idiot and it's going to [ __ ] her
again
like get the money get pregnant again
and then run it back again he's so
stupid he'll do it
yeah but to say that he's not a [ __ ]
idiot he's a [ __ ] idiot he's a
[ __ ] idiot you gizzard anybody
pregnant you don't want to get people
running
yeah
he's a [ __ ] you're just not a loser
oh he's a loser like i think you're a
loser if you're just trying to pay
[ __ ] to get that's some stuff that's
[ __ ] dawg and when you're low-balling
the scumbag that's what i mean whatever
brand that's saying synonyms
you know what i'm saying like think
about what he spent 75 grand on a
[ __ ] necklace probably yeah you know
what i mean like crazy like trips
guaranteed 75 grand there's tons of
[ __ ] that he probably said 75 grand
he's gonna have this kid with him locked
to him guaranteed for the next 18 years
of his life he's going to spend over a
million dollars reading this phrase in
his kit
so
he's a [ __ ] idiot and he's a loser
you remember when he had this [ __ ] i
don't know if you remember this he had
some like high and mighty speeches i
remember nothing about him he this is it
forever he was being headlined for two
days a coach they asked him if some
coach inspired him he said if i ever
need a coach to inspire me i'll retire
from the league the day i need a coach
to inspire me to play hard i'll retire
so that
coach can inspire you to play hard but a
[ __ ] kid can inspire you to retire
and not be in his life oh no that's not
why the kid is doing he just noses up
he's just trying to [ __ ] i know hold
her hostage but you still need your
scumbag yeah it's a scumbag amount of
money it's a scumbag message it's got me
to keep cheating on chloe if you marry
do her stop impregnating other women at
least pull out
ain't nobody even saying don't cheat
just don't get them pregnant like that's
where you're a [ __ ] idiot
pull out
dmx's wife says some [ __ ] like i could
handle the other women but when he got
like five girls pregnant i couldn't do
it i had to be out oh man i saw that
documentary on him oh how was that
rough probably sad huh yeah [ __ ] dude
rest in peace yeah
it's good though you should check it out
if you he's just a is a wild figure man
engaging figure
a loser
son he's a scumbag
i just couldn't imagine seeing this guy
on the street being like wow what a
loser that guy is
i'm like you might be a scumbag might be
a funnier scumbag
i try to be nicer about it
scumbag is awful to be i'd rather be a
loser than a scumbag a piece of scum
i don't know i mean i get the point yeah
i would be too but i don't know if he's
a loser you are splitting hairs
who's a winner bro
who's a winner to you yeah is he a
winner
yeah
i mean maybe i mean
in life yeah
now he's a christian he's one of them
chris oh really tom brady's a winner
that guy's a winner tom brady's a winner
yeah tristan thompson is tom brady to
you
no i just said he's tom brady cheating
as a girl just because you don't just
because you don't lose the girl after
the kid oh yeah oh that's a
and the winner took care of the kid you
know
that's consistent yeah
didn't send some [ __ ] slimy text
message
winners though 60 million dollar
contract
you